Commencement is the signature event on the
MIT campus. So then to be asked to create the
opening music video to this big event, also
knowing that tens of thousands of people
were gonna be ready and waiting to watch this
live. That was a real honor and a real privilege
[Instrumental music playing]
There's a big dream with this piece. I remember
when Fred first told us about this piece,
he was like everyone's going to be in it.
Every single person we could possibly get
is going to be in this piece,
and Fred a man of big ideas.
We're talking about marshaling
200 people, it was a little crazy.
[Instrumental music playing]
It wasn't just going to be Jazz Band. It
was going to be the Vocal Jazz Ensemble.
It was going to be a cappella groups. It was going
to be MITSO. It was going to be Wind
Ensemble. It was going to be Choir.
[Instrumental music playing]
My first thought was wow this is going to be
such an epic way to celebrate commencement.
♪ To the list of things that make me sad ♪
The lyrics from the piece were taken
from poetry submitted by MIT students.
The tone of it was really personal. A lot of it
kind of achingly painful and difficult but with
glimmers of hope and sense of trying to prevail,
trying to overcome the challenges of the pandemic.
♪ Just gray and gray and gray ♪
[Instrumental music playing]
I felt very much that that was reflective
of our pandemic experience.
It started out really tough and by the time that wewere recording this we were flourishing.
♪ Look at the sky and remember ♪
We're going to acknowledge the
seriousness and the devastation
that the pandemic has caused. At the same time
we're going to try to learn from this experience
and not just go back to normal because
there is no more going back to normal.
♪ Look at the sky ♪
Being outside in the Stata amphitheater and
playing trumpet alongside the Festival JazzEnsemble.
It was an awesome experience because
I actually hadn't really played with people
like live for an entire year, basically.
There was a certain energy that everyone
had because we finally got to see everybody
together in the same place playing together.
It felt like a great send-off
sort of to our senior year.
♪ Overwriting the written constellations ♪
It was pretty amazing that they moved a piano
and drum kit outside the Stata.
A beautifulupright piano being able to play on the
real instrument made such a difference.
♪ I trace my finger ♪
I want the music video to bring something to the
music that isn't there by just hearing the song.
[Instrumental music playing]
If you're able to cut to a certain
instrumentalist at a certain time,
you'redrawing the listener to hearing such a booming
instrument that comes in right at that time.
♪ crack in the door ♪
[Instrumental music playing]
What i wanted to do in the shooting is
to have an improvisational aspect to it
so that all the camera people present
could really use their eyes and ears to frame what
looked like the right thing to see at that time.
[Instrumental music playing]
Jamshied, I think is really good when it comes to
writing for guitar he really gets
what makes guitar song good. And
so he has his own guitar and he sent the video
of him playing the part.
Hey Sebastian there'sprobably other ways to play the chords but
this sounded good to me on a DADGAD tuning.
[Guitar music playing]
So you'll make this thing right? Okay thanks man.
[Instrumental music playing]
♪ This is the beginning ♪
It's using what we call an open tuning.
So we detune the strings of the guitar
to be able to play different chords and the
whole guitar sounds different when you do that.
♪ Again and again
It is the beginning ♪
A good guitar part can be really fun to
play and this is definitely one of those.
Such a climactic moment in the music.
That is what you play music for moments like those.
[Instrumental music playing]
♪ We are fragile we are precious ♪
♪ We are fragile ♪
The music department has given so
much to me in terms of experiences
and friendships. So it was really great to be able
to represent music at MIT through this performance.
♪ We are fragile
We are precious ♪
♪ Who will listen ♪